Martin Archambault est l'un des
pionniers de la conduite électrique au
Québec il anime balado sur le sujet il
roule dans une Chevrolet Bolt depuis
deux ans un modèle qui cessera d'être
fabriqué d'ici la fin de l'année qu'on
est triste à disparaître un peu dans le
sens où c'est une bonne petite voiture
abordable c'est probablement le meilleur
rapport qualité-prix actuellement sur le
marché Général Motors va remplacer la
Baule une compacte par une version
entièrement électrique de la Chevrolet
Ekinoxe un véhicule utilitaire sport il
sera vendu sous les 40000 dollars un peu
moins cher que la bolt et sera équipée
de la nouvelle plateforme de batterie de
JM qui offre une plus grande autonomie
mais qui prend plus d'espace résultat le
véhicule sera plus imposant 70 cm plus
long 15 cm plus large quand on vit en
milieu urbain qu'on veut se déplacer à
Montréal à Québec puis on se ta pratique
d'avoir une petite voiture qui est plus
manœuvrable il y en
[Musique]
les camions légers sont maintenant plus
nombreux que les automobiles standard
sur les routes du pays de 1990 à 2018
leur nombre à grimper de 280% contre
seulement 10% pour les autos même si la
vente de modèles à essence sera interdit
à compter de 2035 au Canada et
quittèrent souhaite que les
gouvernements imposent des normes aux
constructeurs pour limiter la taille des
véhicules fabriqués il y a cette
notion-là de dire c'est électrique donc
il y a pas d'impact environnemental or
c'est faux il y a quand même des impacts
dans tout ce qu'on produit il y a un
impact environnemental et plus on
produit des choses qui sont grosses plus
l'impact environnemental est important
parce que plus ça prend des matériaux
pour l'instant le véhicule électrique
suit la même trajectoire que le véhicule
à essence les petits modèles sont mis au
rancart même s'ils sont parfois en forte
demande comme la Honda Fit ou encore le
Toyota Yaris et petite voiture
disparaissent souvent au profit de
modèles qui sont construits avec les
mêmes éléments mécaniques et qui sont
vendus plus cher tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont une forme un peu plus de
multi segments c'est le cas selon lui de
la Yandé venioux un multi segment
compact qui a remplacé l'accent avant ce
qu'on avait dans la gamme de Hyundai
c'était la accent qui était une petite
voiture à ion plus bas qui consommait
moins d'essence qui coûtait beaucoup
moins cher on parle de 4-5000 dollars
d'écart ces deux véhicules là utilisent
le même moteur la même boîte de vitesse
les mêmes trains roulants simplement que
le veniou lui il a un look un peu plus
baroudeur aventurier mais il y a même
pas disponible avec quatre roues
motrices donc c'est vraiment pour avoir
le look du vus mais dans le fond on se
retrouve assis dans la même petite
voiture qu'avant et règle générale plus
les véhicules sont gros plus ils sont
chers les consommateurs moins fortunés
sont prises au piège c'est difficile
d'avoir un petit véhicule budget si on
veut avec des mensualités là sous les
400$ par pour moi c'est presque devenu
impossible le Québec on est un
microcosme à l'intérieur de l'Amérique
qui est un monde de grosses bagnole le
rêve américain le gros stations c'est un
peu le concept de la peau les levain
tant qu'on offrira pas des petites
voitures les gens pourront pas réaliser
que c'est quelque chose d'intéressant
pour eux faute de choix Martin
Archambault pourrait bien opter pour
l'équinoxe quand la location de sale
arrivera à échéance est-ce que j'ai
besoin de plus gros que la banque
définitivement pas donc s'il y avait un
modèle un peu plus petit de la même
taille ça serait probablement mon
premier choix parce que j'ai pas besoin
de plus gros